Çeviri:
Gözden geçirme: Sancak Gülgen
Oh be!
Ali bana bir ay önce, "TEDxReset 2015'te
konuşur musun?"
dediğinden beri karın ağrısından
kurtulamamıştım.
Geceleri uyuyamıyordum.
Çıktım ya, şimdi rahatladım.
Nasıl olsa gerisi gelir.
Ali sağ olsun, benden fikri yakalama
oturumunda konuşmamı istedi.
Ben en çok bu oturumda konuşmak isterdim.
Çünkü bu sürecin içinde beni
en çok heyecanlandıran
en çok ilgilendiren
en çok böyle kalbimi pır pır
attıran şey
o fikir oluşturma kısmı.
Hani "ideation" dediğimiz şey.
Hani şu, "A-ha!"
Ali de kullandı bu lafı.
Niye "A-ha!" diyoruz ya?
"A-ha" diye bir kelime var mı?
Bu Amerikanca, bunun Türkçesi nedir?
"Hah!"
Bir de, "Haaa..." var.
Bir de, "Aaa...".
Bakın, çok ilginç.
"a" ve "h" kullanılıyor hep.
Bunun fikirle bir alakası var, galiba.
Bu "A-ha!" anı var ya,
ya da "Hah!" anı var ya.
Yani böyle bir aydınlanma anı.
Sırtınızdan aşağı böyle soğuk soğuk
terlerin döküldüğü bir an.
Elleriniz terliyor, böyle ne bileyim
hormonlar falan çalışıyor.
Nöronlar... Biraz aşktan bahsediyor
gibiyim, değil mi?
Bence çok benzer duygular
uyandırıyor insanda.
Bir fikirle ilk defa tanışmak.
Dolayısıyla ben bu konuya biraz kafa
yordum, biraz da meslek icabı
öğrencilerle, hani fikir geliştirme
süreçleri içinde bulunduğumdan
çok yaygın gördüğüm fikir mitleri
üzerine bir kurgu yaptım.
Yani birçok insanın düşündüğü, inandığı;
ben dahil, benim tanıştığım insanlar.
Ama aslında doğru olmayan mitler.
1. mitimiz, şöyle bir resimle
başlıyorum.
Çok meşhur bir tablo.
Andy Warhol, biliyorsunuz.
"Herkes hayatta 15 dakikalığına
meşhur olacak."
Bu da benim 15 dakikam belki.
Ama... bu benim versiyonum.
"Herkesin bir tane iyi fikri olacak."
Hiç unutmuyorum, annemle ilkokuldayken,
konuşurken
"Anne, ne diye, işte böyle, ben yeni
bir şey düşünemiyorum?" falan dediğimde
"Bekle oğlum, iyi bir fikir gelecek
senin de aklına." dedi.
Ve ben iyi bir fikir bekliyorum.
Ya ilk defa size itiraf edeceğim.
Benim yüksek lisansım yok,
biliyor musunuz?
Ben lisanstan sonra
doktoraya devam ettim.
Niye, biliyor musunuz?
Hocama gittim, "Hocam, dersler bitti."
dedim. "Şimdi n'apıcaz?"
"Valla," dedi, "işte master tezi
yazman lazım."
"Veyahut da direk doktoraya
devam edebilirsin."
Şimdi gittim, düşündüm.
"Ulan master tezi..."
"Ya benim bir tane iyi fikrim varsa?"
"Onu da mastera kullanırsak,
doktoraya n'apıcaz sonra?"
Bakın benim resuméme,
master görmezsiniz.
Tek kurşunum olduğunu düşündüm
o zamanlar.
Ne kadar safmışım!
Şimdi bakıyorum.
Ya işte, yeni bir ders açayım,
yeni bir yüksek okul başlatayım.
kitap yazayım, blog yazayım
liselere yetkinlik eğitimi vereyim,
girişim fabrikası zincirleri açayım.
Yani derler ya,
"Çok fazla fikir
ve çok az zaman."
Vaktimiz yok bütün fikirlere yetişmeye.
Dolayısıyla rahat olun.
İyi fikirler çok gelecek size.
2. mitimiz, "Fikir Borsası".
Çok iyi fikirler, işte mükemmel fikirler
1 milyon, çok iyi fikirler yüz bin.
Burada kötü fikir yok, gördüğünüz gibi.
Kötünün iyisi fikirler 10.
Ya böyle bir inanç var ortalıkta.
Bana gelip de,
"Hocam çok iyi bir fikrim var
sana satmak istiyorum." diyen
öğrenciler oldu.
"Gel bu fikri götürelim,
bir melek yatırımcıya
satalım." diyen öğrenciler oldu.
Onlara biraz üzülerek söyledim.
"Ya, kusura bakma ama;
fikrin bini bir para."
Değeri sağlayan şey icraattir.
İcraat yoksa değer yok.
İcraat dediğimiz de; fikrin yanına takımı
koyacaksın, teknolojiyi koyacaksın
finansmanı koyacaksın ve
piyasayı koyacaksın.
Ancak o zaman değer yaratacaksın.
Bunla biraz bağlantılı başka bir yanılgı.
Belki biliyorsunuzdur bu Kurt Cobain
şarkısını, "Man Who Sold The World".
Aslında orijinali David Bowie'dir.
Başka bir örnek, "Sinéad O'connor,
Nothing Compares To You".
Bu da bir Prince şarkısıdır aslında ama
kopyaları orijinallerinden çok daha
tanınan, meşhur şarkılar.
Orijinali makbul diye bir saplantı var.
Aranızda "AltaVista" diye bir
arayıcı kullanan var mı?
AltaVista.
Yıl 1995, n'oldu AltaVista'ya?
Yıl 1995, Netscape 2.9 milyar dolara
halka arz edildi.
Yıl 2000, AOL'ye 10 milyar dolara
satıldı.
Bugün nerede Netscape?
Bugün ne kullanıyoruz?
Google kullanıyoruz.
Google peki kaçıncı arama motoruydu?
21. arama motoruydu.
Fikrin orijinal olması
ancak bu kadar önemli işte.
Tek örnek bu mu?
Hayır, çok örnek var.
Blockbuster piyasayı değiştirdi.
Çünkü o pahalı DVD'leri artık kiralamak
zorunda kalmıyorduk.
Pardon satın almak zorunda kalmıyorduk,
kiralayabiliyorduk.
Arkadan Netflix geldi, ben de aynı
şeyi yaparım ama
bir hafta tutacağına ben sana bunu
postayla göndereyim
sen bana geri gönder, daha hızlı
çevireyim. Yeni bir iş modeliyle geldi.
Ondan sonra yavaş yavaş da
internetten kiralamalar başladı.
Blockbuster, ya bunlar n'apıyo
falan derken...
... baktık bugün ortada Blockbuster yok.
Netflix babalar gibi yoluna devam ediyor.
Kendi sektörüm, Bologna Üniversitesi,
1088 yılında kuruldu.
Bugün ilk 100 üniversite arasında var mı?
Yok.
İlk 200'e? Eh, ancak girmeye çalışıyor.
Türkiye'nin ilk üniversitesi, İstanbul
Üniversitesi, 1933 yılında kuruldu.
Ama sonradan daha farklı bir modelle
gelen, Amerikan modelini kullanan
üniversiteler bazı alanlarda İstanbul
Üniversitesi'ni geçtiler, ondan da sonra
iş modelini de değiştiren bazı vakıf üniversiteleri
yine İstanbul Üniversitesi'ni geçtiler.
Dolayısıyla, hani "first-mover advantage"
denir ya, "ilk adım atma avantajı".
Her zaman geçerli değil.
Bir tane daha örnek vereceğim.
Coursera'dan bahsedildi, Udacity,
işte edX'ten bahsedildi.
"Fathom.com"u hatırlayan var mı aranızda?
Bunların ağababası. 2000 yılında
Columbia Üniversitesi
milyonlarca dolar döktü bu
uzun mesafeli eğitime.
Ama bir şeyi unuttular.
Aslında eğitimin değeri yok,
değeri olan şey diploma.
Diplomayı veremiyorsan, kimse senin
eğitimine para vermiyor.
Milyonlarca dolara çok güzel bir şey
öğrendi Colombia Üniversitesi ki...
Esas değer verilen şey diploma.
Dolayısıyla yine burada da orijinalin
önemli olmadığını gördük.
Önemli olan nedir?
Zaman önemli, yer önemli,
uygulama önemli.
Hani, "Fikrim orijinal değil."
Olsun.
Buyrun işte, "gittigidiyor" ne yaptı?
e-Bay'i kopyaladı.
Türkiye'ye getirdi.
Ondan sonra döndü e-Bay'e sattı.
Gayet başarılı bir girişim.
Şu ana kadar Türkiye'den çıkan...
Yani gülüyorsunuz ama
ben girişimcilere bunu öneriyorum.
Ya "İlla orijinal fikir peşinde
olmayın kardeşim." diyorum.
"İspatlanmış fikri getirin Türkiye'ye."
Çünkü getirdiğiniz zaman lokalize etmek
için zaten bir sürü orijinallik yapmanız
gerekecek. "gittigidiyor" birebir
kopyalamadı ki E-bay'i.
Türkiye şartlarına uydurdu,
üstüne koydu.
220 milyon dolara da sattılar.
Şimdi İnşaallah ondan daha büyük bir satış
bekliyoruz, eli kulağında yakında ama.
Şu ana kadar Türkiye rekoru
bir orijinalde değil, bir kopyada.
Dolayısıyla, uygulama önemli.
Benzer bir mit.
Öğrencilerden en çok gelen şikayet.
"Ya Hocam, çok iyi bir fikrim var
ama söylemem."
"Nasıl yani?"
"Hocam çalarlar."
"O zaman hadi bana eyvallah."
diyorum, gidiyorum.
"Hocam, bir dakika,
ısrar etmeyecek misin?"
"Ben söylemek istiyorum ama
çalarlar diye korkuyorum."
Ya çok zor bir şey buna
ikna olmak ama
güneşin altında yeni
hiç bir şey yok, arkadaşlar.
Sizin aklınıza bir fikir düştüyse,
aynı fikir
Endonezya'da da birinin aklına düşüyor,
İsveç'te de birinin aklına düşüyor.
Hani, "İnternet benim fikrimi çaldı."
"Ya Facebook'u ben zaten
düşünmüştüm abi."
"Ya Twitter'ı da.
Ama benimki 150 karakterdi."
"Şöyle dolu dolu küfretmek için
150 karakter gerekiyordu."
"Onu 140'a indirdi Amerikalı,
zengin oldu."
Yok böyle bir şey.
Yeni, orijinal diye bir fikir yok.
Dolayısıyla çalarlar diye
dertlenmeyeceğiz.
Çünkü sahiplenmek için icraatte
bulunmamız lazım, hareket etmemiz lazım.
Çalarlar, diye fikirden bahsetmemek,
fikrinize yapabileceğiniz en büyük ihanet.
Bol bol fikri paylaşmanız lazım ki
fikir gelişsin, güzelleşsin, büyüsün.
Benzer bir mit daha.
Bugün bir bankanın eğitim
akademisinin danışma kurulundaydım.
Şu klavyeyi gördüm orada,
bu resmi gördüm.
Bankanın kullandığı ilk klavye.
Bildiğiniz "Q" klavye.
Buradaki inovasyon ne,
biliyor musunuz?
Yazma işini mekanize etmek.
Dolayısıyla çok önemli bir iş yapmış.
Ama klavyenin neden Q'nun,
W'nun E'nin, A'nın, Z'nin
oralarda olduğunu hiç düşündünüz mü?
Hani mitoloji bu aslında ama
bana da inanılır geliyor.
Satmaya çalışanlar, "Bak ne güzel yazıyor,
'typewriter', hepsi 1. sırada."
"Adam harfleri aramadan 'typewriter'ı
1. sıradan basabilsin." diye diyorlar.
2. bir mitoloji.
Bunu kasten böyle yapmışlar ki
daktilograflar çok hızlı yazmasın,
şu kalkıp kalkıp vuran kafalar var ya.
Onlar birbirine karışmasın.
Yani kasten kötü tasarlanmış
bir klavyeden bahsediyoruz.
Buradaki mit ne peki ve
bu klavyeyi biz aynen aldık,
şu anda laptoplarımızda kullanıyoruz,
bilgisayarlarımızda kullanıyoruz.
Buradaki mit, iyi fikrin kötü fikri
kovacağı miti.
Yani, benim fikrim daha iyi,
demek ki benim fikrim çok para yapar
başarılı olur, kazanırım.
Böyle bir şey yok.
O 'Q klavye' dediğimiz şeyde
ağırlık sol elde.
Ve vuruşların sadece %20'si orta sırada.
En rahat olduğumuz orta sırada.
Parmaklar arasında dağılım da
son derece dengesiz.
3-4 parmağa çok ağır yük biniyor.
Ha, bunu değiştirmişler, düzeltmişler
endüstri mühendisleri.
Dvorak çıkmış, arkasından Colemak çıkmış.
Mükemmel tasarımlar yapmışlar.
İki misli hızlandırmışlar.
Ama bunu kullanan insan sayısı
%2-3'ün altında.
Çünkü "network effect" dediğimiz şey var.
Bir kere dünya bu Q klavyeyi satın almış.
Sen Dvorak öğreniyorsun, arkadaşının
makinasını kullanman gerekiyor.
Hadi bakalım Q klavye.
Dolayısıyla geçemiyoruz.
Aynı sebepten dolayı Amerika
metrik sisteme geçemiyor.
Dolayısıyla bir fikrin daha iyi olması
başarılı olmasını getirmiyor.
Böyle bir ön şarttan da
yola çıkmamak gerekiyor.
6. mitimiz "Fikir Gurusu".
Bu film daha Türkiye'ye gelmedi
yanılmıyorsam ama yakında gelecek.
Fikir uzmanları olduğunu
düşünüyor öğrenciler.
Ve gidiyorlar, fikirlerini danışıyorlar.
Hani, "Ne düşünüyorsun bu fikir hakkında?"
Fakat maalesef özellikle Türkiye'de,
bakın ben başka ülkelerde de
girişimcilerle bir araya geldim,
özellikle Türkiye'de fikir uzmanlarından
çok fikir katilleri var.
"Ha o zaten var ya."
"Sen mi yapacaksın?"
Ya da, "Ben onu düşünmüştüm, olmaz o."
Bunlar fikir vakumları.
Fikir hırsızları,
esas hırsızlar bunlar.
Çünkü sizin o kendinize güveninizi
çalıyorlar.
Sizin bir şeyler yaratma isteğinizi
öldürüyorlar.
Dolayısıyla fikrinizi birine danışırken
çok fazla önem vermeyeceksiniz
onların ne dediğine.
Çünkü en uzman diye bildiğimiz
insanların bile
söyledikleri şeylerin birkaç
tanesine göz atalım.
Yok işte, "Hiç kimsenin evine bilgisayar
alması gerekmeyecek." diyor adam.
Bu arada DEC battı şu anda,
batmış durumda.
"32 bit operating sistemimiz olmayacak."
diyordu Gates,
şu anda 64 bite geçmiş durumdayız.
"Apple öldü!" diyor adam.
730 milyar dolarlık bir şirket.
iWatch'ı piyasa beğenmedi diye,
35 milyar piyasa değeri düştü.
Türk Hava Yolları 4.5 milyar,
yapın siz hesabı.
"Battı, öldü." dediği şirket.
"Yok işte hiç kimse e-commerce
kullanmaz." diyor Time Magazine.
Ve böyle gidiyor.
Dolayısıyla, hani, bu adamlar bile bu
kadar devasa hatalar yapabiliyorlarsa,
uzmanlarım bizim fikrimiz hakkında
ne dediği o kadar önemli değil.
Biraz daha inatçı ve azimli olmak
gerekiyor.
Son mitimize geldik.
Bu da, biliyorsunuz, Roden'in
düşünen adam heykeli.
İlk gördüğümde çok etkilenmiştim ve
burada sadece estetik güzellik değil,
bir ruhani bir mesaj olduğunu düşünmüştüm.
Yani posture şu olmalı:
Sağ el, sol diz, sol şöyle
falan düşünülmeli.
Oturdum, düşündüm falan böyle.
Fikrim gelecek, fikrim-
Hiçbir şey gelmiyor.
Cin falan, peri anlattılar.
Cini bekledik, periyi bekledik.
O da gelmedi.
Buradaki mit de şu:
"Fikir üretimi bireysel bir aktivitedir.
İyi bir fikir için çok düşünmek gerekir.
Fikir de bir ilham perisinden gelir."
Oturuyorum, bekliyorum;
fikir gelecek.
Bunun tam tersi,
fikir üretimi bir grup aktivitesi.
Fikirler grup bilincinden,
grup zekasından çıkıyor.
Dolayısıyla, fikrin çıkacağı ortam
aslında bu.
O düşünen adam heykeli değil.
Bir kahve.
Bakın, orada şu 3 tanesi oturmuşlar;
sol taraftaki 3 tanesi bir iş konuşuyor.
Arkadaki 2 tanesi yeni bir operadan
bahsediyorlar.
İşte orada bir tane adam,
o evet garson kıza sarkıntılık yapıyor.
Fazla bir şey değişmemiş.
Şu adam da kahveyi yönetenden bir,
"Burada ben bir düğün yapmak istiyorum."
Ya da işte "Felsefe günü düzenleyeceğim."
falan.
Fikirler böyle ortamlardan çıkar.
Dolayısıyla, bir Starbucks'a gittiğiniz
zaman Amerika'da,
özellikle San Fransisko'da
veya Boston'da New York'ta,
insanlar sürekli iş fikirleri konuşurlar
kendi aralarında.
Ve sürekli birbirlerinin fikirlerini
geliştirmeye çalışırlar.
Bu tam anlamıyla bir takım aktivitesidir.
Dolayısıyla, ortak çalışma merkezleri
bu kadar önemlidir.
Birlikte başarmanın bu kadar geri olduğu
bir kültüre bunu anlatmak çok zor oluyor
ama; "Arkadaşlar yapacaksanız
beraber yapacaksınız."ı
anlatmak gerekiyor insanlara.
Kuluçka merkezi bu yüzden önemlidir.
Birazcık da yaratıcılık yönetiminden
bahsedeyim.
Böyle bir şey yok aslında.
Yaratıcılığı yönetemezsin.
Yaratıcılık "için" yönetebilirsin ancak.
Yaratıcılığın ortaya çıkacağı
alanları oluşturmak.
O da aslında bizlerin işi,
eğitmenlerin işi.
Aslında Dilek Hocam'ın bunu ne kadar
iyi yaptığını gördükten sonra
buraya çıkıp konuşmak epey zor oluyor
benim için ama.
1-2 tane hikayeyi ben anlatayım size.
İkisi de benim başımdan geçti.
Öğrencilerden bir tanesi geldi.
Üniversiteyi açmışız, 1. yılın sonunda
"Hocam, üniversitede kahve makinesi yok.
Ben kahve makinesi koymak
istiyorum." dedi.
"Buyur, koy oğlum." dedik,
gitti bir şirketle anlaştı.
Baktım tamamen yüzde üzerine çalışacak,
sorun değil.
Eyvallah. İlk gün kahveyi getirdi.
"Hocam, buyrun kahvenizi."
Aradan birkaç ay geçti,
"Hocam, bir anlaşmazlık çıktı aramızda".
"N'oldu?"
"Ya işte, onlar benim para hesabını
karıştırdığımı iddia ediyorlar.
Ben de onların malları zamanında
getirmediğini düşünüyorum.
Beni dava ediyorlar."
"E, niye dava ediyorlar, Semihciğim?"
"Ben bir yanlışlık yapmışım,
üniversite adına kontrat imzalamışım.
Böyle bir hakkım yokmuş
benim meğerse."
"Ha, peki buyur, üniversitenin avukatını
al, git, problemi çözün."
Şirkete gittik, "Ya yapmayın, etmeyin.
Bu çocuk tazedir, yenidir.
Hadi iki ay daha kalın,
ondan sonra çıkın."
Tekrar geri geldi. "Bak dedim, Semih,
yine başlıyorsun. Bir kere daha dene."
"Bu sefer tamam, Hocam." dedi.
"Dışarıdan kiralamıyorum.
Kendim işi yapacağım.
Bir tane de ortağım var."
"Ortakla ortaklık sözleşmesi
imzaladın mı, Semihciğim?"
"Hocam, ne gerek var.
Bir Türk çocuğuyuz, el sıkıştık."
Peki. Aradan 1 ay geçti.
Semih tekrar geldi.
"Hocam," dedi, "adam 'Ben parayı
koydum, sen de emeğini koyacaksın.'
diyor, hiç çalışmıyor."
"Oğlum," dedim, "sözleşmeye yazsaydın
bunları, bu sorun çıkmazdı başına."
O problemi de atladık, ondan sonra
iş yürüdü. Yürümeye devam ediyor falan.
Geldi bana, "Hocam," dedi, "ben
kızlar tuvaletine ped otomatı koyacağım."
Adam otomatlar kralı olma
yolunda hızla ilerliyor.
"Erkekler tuvaletine ne koyacaksın,
Semihciğim?" diye sormadım hiç.
Aradan biraz daha zaman geçti.
"Hocam, bana bir kart bastırır mısın?"
"Ne oğlum?"
"Ben Samsun'a gideceğim. Televizyonda
program gördüm.
Adamın biri simit otomatı yapmış,
Onun İstanbul bayiliğini alacağım."
Hayatımda ilk defa herifi takım elbiseyle
ve çantayla gördüm.
Samsun'a gitti. "Hadi bakalım." dedim.
"Bir yandan da olacak iş mi bu?" ama...
Adam geri geldi, "İstanbul, Ankara ve
İzmir'i aldım dedi."
"E bravo."
Ondan sonra geldi, "Ama" dedi, "otomatları
yapmak için paraya ihtiyaç var."
"Abi," dedim, "bende para yok.
Ama sen bu üniversitede olup da
parası olan birisini tanıyor musun,
Semihciğim?"
Öyle bir, resepsiyon gibi
bir şey var.
"Anladım, Hocam." dedi.
Aradan bir saat geçti.
Hüsnü Bey geldi yanıma, "Ya, adam beni
tuvalette sıkıştırdı, benden para istedi."
Ondan sonra bana geldi, "Ben bankalara
girmek istiyorum.
Beni bankalara girmekte destekle."
Bir telefon ettik işte,
bir tanıdık bankaya.
Çay makinesini, servisini, kaldırdılar
ve bu otomatlardan koydular.
Yani banka da kârlı çıktı, çalışanlar da
memnun. Bedavaya istedikleri zaman
çay kahve içiyorlar.
Çocuk da para kazanmaya başladı.
"Hocam, bir haftada üniversitede üç ayda
kazandığımı kazanıyorum."
demeye başladı.
Şimdi buradaki hikaye, bakın, çocuğa
doğru yolu baştan göstermeye kalksanız,
çocuğun aslında yaratıcılığına ket
vuruyorsunuz.
Çocuk sizin memurunuz haline geliyor.
Ben bilmiyor muydun onun o hataları
yapacağını?
Ama o hataları yapmasına
izin vermek gerekiyor.
Hata yaptığı zaman, düştüğü zaman,
tekrar kaldırıp
yola devam etmesini sağlamak gerekiyor.
Bir sonraki dönem bir çocuk geldi.
"Hocam, ben bir para bozma makinesi
koymamız gerektiğini düşünüyorum.
Kahveye, makina yok dedi.
"Oğlum," dedim, "peki nasıl para
kazanacaksın?"
"10 lira koyacaklar,
9 lira vericem ben." dedi.
"Öğrencilerle konuştun mu bunu,"
dedim, "müşteriyle?"
Gitti, geldi. " Hocam," dedi,
"'Makinayı kırarız.' diyorlar." dedi.
"Peki nasıl para kazanacak?"
"Hocam, reklam alacağım o zaman." dedi.
"Reklamcılarla konuştun mu?" dedim.
Gitti, geldi. "Hocam,
ayda 50 lira veriyolar." dedi.
"Peki napıcaksın." dedim.
"Ben bir daha düşüneyim." dedi.
Gitti, geldi. "Hocam ben bunu Webpos'a
çevirmeye karar verdim.
Web üzerinden kartla yapacağız.
Karda yükleyeceğiz." dedi.
"Ha bak, şimdi bir yerlere geldin."
Sonunda da bu Akbil gibi bir şey
yaptılar. İşi oraya bağladılar.
Buradaki ana fikir ne?
Çocuğa şu söylenebilirdi:
"Oğlum senin para bozma makinesiyle
işin ne, dersini çalışsana sen."
"Ya da biz büyükleriniz bunu düşünürüz.
Siz kendi işinize bakın."
Veyahut da "O olmaz, çünkü..."
Bunları söylediğiniz zaman çocuğu
söndürüyorsunuz.
Türkiye'de eğitimcilerin
maalesef yaptığı da bu.
Çocuklara alan vermek lazım.
Bırakalım hata yapsınlar.
Bırakalım öğrensinler
ve fikirler yavaş yavaş gelişsin.
Fikirler çok kırılgan, onları böyle
pamuklar üzerinde tutmamız gerekiyor.
Kapatıyorum.
Fikir sembolü.
Ampul veya bomba kullanılıyor
Türkiye'de.
Bomba bir defa patlıyor, yok ediyor.
Ampul bir defa aydınlanıyor,
açıyorsun kapıyorsun bitiyor.
Ben bunların doğru semboller olduğunu
düşünmüyorum.
Bence fikir sembolü,
fikrin organik olduğunu
temsil eden bir fidan
Çevresiyle sürekli iletişim halinde
olduğunu ve değiştiğini belirten bir fidan.
Fikir fidanlarınız bol olsun.
Fidanlarınız ağaç olsun.
Ağaçlarınız meyve versin.
Teşekkürler.